to Pakistan now where Security Forces
say an operation to free hostages from
Taliban fighters is now over troops
formed a high security detention center
in the Northwest where gunmen had been
holding several people since Sunday
efforts to negotiate with the hostage
takers had failed so let's bring in
Kamal Haider who's in Islamabad so come
out the operation is over what's the
latest you're hearing about how it
unfolds in any possible casualties
what reports we have been getting have
been from local sources the military has
not issued a statement yet but what we
know so far is that the operation got
underway a few hours ago and people were
able to witness plumes of black smoke
billowing out of that compound and heard
the rattle of gunfire now the government
had asked the residents of nearby areas
to stay indoors because there was a fear
that those who were holding hostages
inside that counter-terrorism department
situated in a highly secure area May fan
out and cause Mayhem schools were closed
internet services were closed and the
military Special Operations units moved
in on that compound now according to the
reports that we have received so far six
of those hostage takers have been killed
our drones were used in this particular
operation and of course after every
military tree operation or a rescue
operation of this sort of mop-up
operations continue so that's what we've
been told so far six of those hostage
takers have been killed seven of the
security forces Personnel have been
wounded in storming that
counter-terrorism department uh
fortified unit inside as I mentioned
Banu Cantonment which is a military area
what led up to this event Kamal
well earlier on Sunday this
counter-terrorism department building in
Banu was interrogating the prisoners
these are said to be terica Taliban
Pakistan Fighters during that
interrogation they overpowered the
interrogators took them hostage and
distributed the weapons that they found
on the complex to their other fellow
detainees who were being held there then
they issued a request that they wanted a
safe evacuation from the area that they
would take the hostages with them would
release them once they were on a safer
location but the military surrounded the
area and stormed that particular Center
they of course had been requested
evacuation and despite frantic efforts
to negotiate a peaceful way out of this
talks failed and there was no other
option but for the military forces to go
in thank you for that update
there in Islamabad